[Music]
on today's show we have a hard dark
episode so watch out for the little ears
in the room we talk about psychosis we
talk about leaving a marriage after just
a few years in we talk with a young mom
of two little kids who's slowly losing
herself and she wants to get her old
self back stay tuned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what up what up this is john with the dr
john deloney show so glad you're with us
i hope you're doing well if your
family's well
it has been a chaotic
cha-cha blizzard the last month in this
country
and um
man with overseas stuff with the weather
with fires with
flooding it's been a mess
so i hope you're i hope you're well hope
you're settled in your spirit i hope
you're doing what you can in your local
community to have peace to make sure
that you and your loved ones and those
that you have influence over are
i hope you're turning off all the
electronics and the doom scrolling and
the new news and the new news and the
new clicks and the new bright lights and
auntie and
i hope you're talking to real people
hope you're talking to real people if
you're really concerned and all of us
should be about what's going on in
afghanistan
call a veteran talk to somebody
like talk to a real person make eye
contact with somebody
if you're worried about what's going on
in haiti as we all should be
um
call somebody you know who's got some
connections there
talk to real people um
and don't just live in this this click
bait ecosystem that we're in right if
you call somebody who's experiencing the
fires call somebody who's experiencing
this crazy rain on the east coast the
hurricane whatever
call real people okay call real people
it just changes how we interpret and
internalize and feel tough news right so
whatever's going on in your world and
that doesn't even man cove it's just
bananas people are sick schools are back
in session so everybody's dealing with
so so much make sure you're connecting
to real
people
and i started a thing the other day and
i just thought i'd pass it along i got
it from um
i was trying to what's the name of the
book it's called ruthless elimination of
hurry and it's a book by john mark comer
and i think it's from an old dallas
willard quote um the ruthless
elimination of hurry but
man this is a practice that i've kind of
rolled my eyes and i thought i'll give
it a shot
and it's been really hard because i
drive like an idiot i drive too fast i
just do
and i don't pay attention very much i'm
always in a hurry to get one place to
the next and so one of the things that
comer suggests is
just drive the speed limit maybe one
mile an hour under it
i gotta roll my eyes
it has been really hard for me to drive
the speed limit here's why because i'm
usually late i'm usually racing out of
my house five minutes after i should
have left or ten or fifteen
which means i gotta drive like crazy to
get where it is i'm going and that means
i arrive all frazzled whether i think
i'm cool and collected or not i'm all
frazzled
and i get there everything's compulsing
and i come into the next that meeting or
the recording or whatever i'm hot i'm
just like this is electrified
and all of a sudden i started driving
the speed limit just as a practice
and that meant i had to leave earlier
which meant i had to get up a couple
minutes earlier which meant i had to go
to bed a few minutes earlier right this
is starting to impact a lot
it means i'm walking into the building
not frantic
and i'm coming into my first meetings a
little bit chill i've had people ask me
hey are you okay and i'm doing great
just my heart rate is
it's normal you know 55 or 60 beats a
minute not uh 130 because my
brain was at ludicrous speed right
so that's my challenge
i want you just to take a week two weeks
just drive the speed limit wherever it
is you go
set crews if you have to i have to i got
to i just get to daydreaming
set the cruise control and drive try
driving the speed limit just get in
places with a little bit less
a little bit less frantic
and just let that piece ripple
throughout your day it's been pretty
remarkable in my life i don't know
i don't know it's been pretty amazing so
there you go
all right let's go to rachel in
nashville tennessee rachel what are you
doing how's it going
it's going great john thank you for
having me here thank you for calling so
what in the world you're in my
neighborhood so i'm going to be extra
nice right
um so what's going on how's it going i'm
from california oh
it's on now
uh actually you're helping all of our
real estate prices so i'm glad you're
here too so what's up how can i help
so i've been struggling all my life with
anger and violence thoughts and
that's led my husband to be
uh become
from a
kind and patient person to
kind of short and stressed out all the
time
okay
so you've been wrestling with no is
there
violent and
angry thoughts for most of your life
yes tell me about these violent thoughts
it's usually
out of like morbid curiosity of you know
what would happen if i
you know shot everybody or
killed some people with a knife i'm
holding and
even walking into the room it's like how
you know how many people could you get
away with killing before people know
notice you're doing it
or
it
to
solve problems my first thoughts turn to
i could just punch somebody and it can
totally end the conversation right now
okay and then what is what has that what
does the anger feel like where does that
come from
i
i get i'm gonna just assume it's just
from
my mom was a
very tense person okay
she wasn't when i was younger you know
so much but she was very
quick to anger
and it got worse over the years as i
grew up
okay and
that just led to me seeing anger solve
the problems because nobody really
wanted to
um you know
argue with her okay
they would just let things go deal with
the relationship stuff okay
and so now you're married what else have
you
struggled with have you struggled with
um
anxiety before have you struggled to
deal with any sort of past abuse do you
deal with hallucinations like what else
are you are you working with here
i do deal with a lot of hallucinations
that's happened i can remember past
when i was five years old
i've been dealing with them okay i have
had insomnia for a long time but i never
knew it was my mom assumed i was
sleepwalking but in reality i was
actually
you know i would get up in the middle of
night when people weren't awake and i
would wait till they were all asleep and
then i would sneak out and go
crawl around the house and
play with the cats or actually sneak
outside and go wander around the
neighborhood and quietly come back in my
mom doesn't even know i would sneak out
okay
when's the last time you had
hallucinations
yesterday last night tell me about it
it starts out with voices i think i hear
somebody whispering to me and
i can't clearly hear what they're saying
now now i just ignore it to the point
where i don't even care what they're
saying and
then it turns into
um i thought i saw somebody walk into my
room or there's somebody outside hanging
out my window
i just learned to ignore it okay
but if my husband's not home i freak out
and will not sleep because it gets worse
because he keeps me grounded if i
if i get too worked up at night where
it's getting really bad and all i can
hear is just screaming and
you know
voices in my head
i can cling to him and know okay he's
real everything's real gotcha we're fine
so when you're in relationship
um
you you can you you understand there's a
gap between what you're experiencing and
what's truly there and when you find
yourself by yourself
as we all do right um those fears
whether they're thoughts or no i can
actually hear that or i can actually i
just saw that shadow i just saw that
trailer
my heart is racing as though somebody is
looking out the window right your body
starts to react for you right um that
gap between what i'm feeling in reality
disappears
and your body says we're not safe right
we got to respond
yeah okay
have you been medicated for this before
have you gone to see somebody
no not at all um before my you know the
you know uh i did have seizures in the
past and
the they were small uh petite mall
seizures and
the
whole i would see things people wouldn't
wouldn't hear about was just left to hey
you're little and you have a active
imagination right i just learned to keep
it quiet because at the time my parents
my mom wouldn't deal with mental issues
very well sure
so what i want to do here um well let me
do this before i start just pipe in here
how can i help are you calling about
this like what to do next or
tell me what's your question
my question is is there a way i can
cope first and first with my anger
because my anger just
blows up and my kids are
getting afraid of me because i will just
start screaming at them and then i catch
myself and just like calm down calm down
they didn't do anything
and
i'm
trying to figure out what can i do where
it doesn't happen anymore
because i just i black out yeah
so number one
what a great mom who's thinking i need
to stop this i don't like where this is
headed
so good for you okay
um that tells me you've got some at
least one foot on the ground in reality
right
and you have a picture of where you want
to be and you also don't have the tools
to get there right now so good for you
for just stopping and saying i need to
get some help okay
um
when i've
the best way i can describe this tell me
if this if this hits home
there become moments
that
you're trying to hold your thoughts
and what you're seeing and or
experiencing right without smelling
hearing
your and the thoughts
and the actions that you know you're
supposed to be doing it feels kind of
like you're trying to hold soup
in your hands
and most of it keeps running out but
you're trying to keep it together but it
just jumbles all together and you're
holding some pieces but it just is does
that make sense it just starts to slip
away
yeah
it really does i often feel like i'm on
a razor's edge between reality and
sanity and i know that
if i slip down to insanity i'm not going
to easily get back
that's right that's right so um
i got some good news for you and some
challenging news okay
the good news is
there is healing here
i think
okay
given your child this has been going on
for a long long time
given that you've got a history of
seizures given that you've got a history
of
um
what i'm gonna guess as a pretty
challenging childhood
um
nothing you're telling me is surprising
okay nothing you're telling me is
freaking me out
i will tell you that the way you have
been able to articulate what's going on
in your mind and in your heart
you need professional psychiatric care
today
okay
and so the violent imagery the i wonder
what if
on top of
anger that can lead to blackout and
there's young kids in the picture and
sometimes i can stay tethered and
sometimes i can't in the hallucinations
plus your history of epilepsy it's time
to go sit down with a psychiatrist and
say
here's what i'm experiencing
and the challenge is that it's what
you're experiencing is a very real brain
issue okay similar to you were lifting
weights and you your elbow broke or you
were playing soccer in the front yard
and you broke your ankle
nobody would look at you and say hey you
have a moral issue
you got bad character
if you go to a doctor no they would say
hey you got to go sit down and see
somebody let them know what's truly
going on
and the
the pharmaceutical interventions on
these things are so
remarkable
here in the 21st century
um and
it's time for you to go do that work
okay and i know that it's scary to say
out loud with somebody
because you think they're gonna take
your kids away or you think that they're
going to
take your control of a situation away
and what i'm telling you is
depending on the nuances of your
situation i'm not hearing that now but i
am hearing that you got to get help
here's what anger is anger points us
towards something that we care about
anger is our body's way of saying this
is really
important to me and it's not the way
it's supposed to be
and your body is going to continue to
respond in that way because it is trying
to make sense of
reality and non-reality all at the same
time
okay
and the more that there's that divide
and as your kids grow up they're going
to do things that don't that you don't
want to do that's just parenting right
and your husband's gonna have these
experiences and the world around you is
gonna have these experiences gonna be
stimulating and overwhelming
you gotta go get the help that you need
and so here's what i'm asking from you
rachel would you commit on behalf of you
on behalf of those little ones of a
husband sounds like he's loves you all
right
will you go call somebody today and say
i need to come in and just
tell you what's been going on in my
whole life will you commit to that
yes
you're worth that
and you live here in my community you're
worth that
does that scare you does that make you
nervous is that a relief
i don't know it's
i guess i'm unsure of if i you know
finding the right person to work with me
sure
i
have trouble talking to a lot of people
um
usually it wears me out and i just want
to go home and that's right
be
you know just with my family or in my
own little place that's exactly right
that's right
and so it's going to be a risk and it's
going to be scary
and what i want you to know is
you're worth a life
without that dark imagery
and you're worth
being able to be in your own home and
that be a place of peace not a place of
terror
and you're worth not having blackout
anger fits
and you're worth having kids who aren't
scared of their mom because deep down
you're a good person and you love your
family
i i try trying to be a good person and i
do love my family i know you do i know
you do i know you do
the person i want you to start loving
that much
is you it's rachel
and that starts with the first time in
your life
for the first time in your life
going to see somebody and saying hey
um i need to get help
i need the voices to stop
and what i'm telling you is you live in
a great city with some great resources
whether you start with your
employee handbook
whether you pick up a phone book and
call vanderbilt psychiatric
whether you call a local counselor and
say hey i need some help and i know this
is going to be bigger than just
something a local counselor can help me
with
but i need to go get some help
[Music]
but you need to do that today
you can do that today
thank you so much for your vulnerability
racial i know this call is hard um
thanks for being willing to tell the
truth and be open
and now i'm looking forward to seeing
what the next chapter in rachel's life
what healing is gonna look like for your
brain i know you're exhausted what's
gonna look like in your family what's
gonna look like with your kids with your
husband all of it
and that starts with you calling a
psychiatrist
and saying i need some help
thank you so much for your vulnerability
rachel we'll be right back on the doctor
john dolan show
hey i want to take a quick break and
talk about something important your
mental health if you cannot find an
in-person counselor in your area or you
can't afford one i've got a solution
i've partnered with better help for
customized online therapy for you video
chat phone or even text chat counseling
with licensed therapists that are going
to help you become a better version of
yourself help you get on the road to
being well go to betterhelp.com
for 10 off your first month this is less
expensive than traditional therapy and
you're worth it betterhelp.com
deloney take care of yourself start
today
all right we are back let's go to bill
in atlanta georgia hey bill what's up
brother
hey dr d it's an honor to be speaking
with you it's an honor to talk to you my
man how can i help today
so
i guess the question i have today is
you know i'm feeling dissatisfied in my
marriage i want to see if it's worth
continuing or not okay tell me about it
so my wife and i started dating when we
were both 15 years old
you know so we've been together for 10
years now two of those we were married
and we still very much love each other
we're best friends and we don't have any
kids together so
um
life is is going pretty good for the
most part but just recently i've been
feeling a lot more dissatisfied with
um
you know me never having dated anyone
else or truly lived the single life um
the single life baby oh you missed it
bill you missed the single life
i did i did so what what is um tell me
what this
what do you think you missed
or even better even better because it's
not over yet what are you missing right
now
not having made a connection with anyone
except for this one person
so what what does that mean you wish
you'd had sex with more people
no not that you wish you'd like got
laugh and hang out and go see how
somebody else dance i mean what what is
the thing help me articulate it
just what you said now it's
seeing other personalities and seeing
what works for me
enjoying
doing new things with someone
and and seeing if they're the right fit
for me and
going through a trial period you know
where you you date and you see they're
good and
things like that it's not so much really
a sexual thing at all it's just more of
did i find the right person for me
and so you've got somebody that you've
been with for 10 years now
married two of those years
and y'all are best friends
and things are going
great and
but there's that nagging feeling that
it could all be better than this
correct
and so when somebody
a let me tell you this you're not crazy
okay
what you're feeling is totally totally
normal
you're not nuts you've been married what
two years now
correct okay
yeah you're not crazy you're 25
correct okay
i don't know
many if anyone
who hasn't wondered
did i do the right thing
especially somebody who's dated somebody
since high school
what would have been like to kiss
somebody else what would it be like to
get to know somebody else's family
and the goal you just described you just
laid out a perfect path of what that
would be like like that anticipation and
that
your heart's beating and you're
putting on cologne for the first time
all the things right you clean your car
out before all that nervous energy that
you get before a date some people hate
that and they love getting married
because that's finally over some people
miss that
i personally miss that okay i love the
apprehension of is this going to go well
is it not going to go well do i hold
somebody's hand and screw up and waste
the whole movie trying to hold
somebody's hand do i guess and see what
kind of gift is going to be good and ah
that wasn't good i miss all that my wife
hated that okay so some people are one
with something the other
but now you find yourself wondering what
would it all be like and i want to do it
all over again so that you can just land
right where you are
with somebody who's your best friend 10
years later
someone that you're sexually compatible
with that you love that things are good
does that make sense
yeah so when you're telling me it's not
the relationship
it is
sounds like you're bored
i am and there is some parts to the
relationship too
there we go what are they
so we're
not the perfect couple of course
everyone has their issues wow but these
are big what are they be honest
and you probably haven't told people
this what are they
i i admit i am ashamed of making this
call i don't like admitting any of this
i don't have anyone to talk to and
here's what i'm telling you you're
helping a bunch of folks because there's
a bunch of people who are in your same
boat
okay absolutely you're being brave
but you're not telling me the full truth
okay so our arguments lately
they've been getting worse more
energetic but energetic it's a
very kind way of saying
violent um
there is
i i don't hit her but
she does know that she has an anger
problem and
you know so being hit isn't
me being hit isn't too much of a
um surprise
so things like that that's a very
critical way your wife is physically
abusing you
not that way it's like is your wife is
your wife hitting you
correct that is physical abuse my
brother
it's not a knock on your masculinity and
i'm tough i can handle it that's
physical abuse okay
call it what it is
all right okay um and so your fights are
getting explosive
fight explosive fights are almost always
a symptom not the problem
what is the gap in your marriage
um
there is
there's forms of resentment of course
there are
me being
dissatisfied like i said earlier and
then
since we've been married
while i was in college and we were
dating she was holding her own well
and she was paying all her bills and
working jobs just to make sure that
she's self-sustaining and ever since we
got married it's things like
her not having a sustainable job
her not i guess
she's trying to look for jobs but she's
not putting her foot forward
to look for that
as much as i would like and so
while we're paying off debt i like the
extra income and since it's not
happening i'm feeling resentment towards
that and she's aware
um
also i'm realizing that our
personalities
don't match anymore since we got married
while we were in dating and i was in
college and high school life was great
because we got along i mean we
practically grew up with each other
dating and so since we got married
everything
kind of shifted in the opposite
direction us our personalities did so i
became more of a tightwad with money and
she's more of she's a very very loose
person when it comes to money she's a
free spirit and in a way that seems to
me as debilitating as long as one comes
in the money comes out life is good
where you know i'm trying to live by
dave ramsey's standards
so it bothers me in that direction
and then our personalities with regards
to
our sense of humor and our conversations
that we have and
um things like her spending a lot of
time on the phone and me spending a lot
of time on the phone it's just been
it's been feeling like we're more
friends than we are a married couple um
and now that
we're adults now we paid bills and we
bought a house and
we had dogs which it kind of counts as
kids although a lot of people can hate
for that
okay can i ask you something
what's up you've got your eye on
somebody else who is it
so that was where i was going next i
know it is who is it
it's it's a friend of a friend a mother
and
we kind of realized that our
personalities meshed perfectly she
actually grew up
20 minutes
ish away from me hold on hold on hold on
hold on hold on hold on just stop
because you created a fantasy now
i did and you're gonna make all of those
puzzle pieces of that fantasy
match
and i'm telling you right now it's not
real
now i'm not saying that your marriage
isn't in trouble it is
but this will not be the solution to
your marriage
okay
i'm telling you
you gotta trust me on this
okay
and it feels so right because everything
in your world feels like it's so wrong
and she has given you the butterflies
she's giving you the
oh yeah everything just meshes right now
and works i'm telling you it doesn't
it's a fantasy it's not real
now you could throw your marriage away
and go date this woman
and decide i'm gonna make this one work
that could happen
but the odds of the exact same thing
happening six months eight months ten
months down the road are astronomical
they're gonna happen
so here's what's happened in your
marriage you all got married and you
quit
you quit wooing each other
you quit leaning into each other you
quit saying hey how can i make his life
better how can i make her life better
and when you got married you started
saying now how this is how this is gonna
be
and she said nope this is how this is
gonna be
and then slowly you guys started
watering the seeds of resentment and it
wouldn't surprise me if she's got her
eyes on somebody else or that she's just
completely parked it
right and then it starts with
sex is a little bit awkward
it's not cruel or invigorating or
exciting because we've chosen for it to
not be
and then we quit trying on dates
and then we just quit going on dates why
don't we just watch a movie we're here
oh and then there's coveted we're stuck
here
right and then you say things like our
personalities don't match anymore i call
bull crap on that
you all are choosing to not be friends
me and my wife my wife thinks that will
ferrell is the least funny person who's
ever lived other than chris farley
and i think the reverse of that i think
she has a mental disorder because she
believes that i think chris farley is
one of the funniest people who's ever
walked the earth followed only by will
ferrell
and phil hartman right so
the fact that we think different things
are funny doesn't mean our personalities
don't match and we should end a 10-year
friendship
it means i'm choosing
to be oppositional to her
right
we've stopped wooing
and what i'm telling you right now is
you're leaning into a fantasy brother
and she is too whether she's got
somebody else that she's got her eye on
or
the fantasy that she's living in which
is i can just do whatever i want with no
consequences i can spend money like
crazy i don't have to work i don't have
to do that that's a fantasy too
but what it doesn't sound like anybody
in your home has done is flip the lights
on and said we've got 10 years
of being best friends of growing up
together
nobody knows us like we each other does
and honey i'm starting to imagine my
life not with you
and i don't want to do that
terrified to lose you
but this is where my head's at that's
where my heart's at
and i feel it's growing way way apart
and vice versa have you done that have
you thrown the lights on turned the
music off and said what are we doing
no
why
why she's worth that you're worth it why
i wanted to avoid the conversation i
have a feeling i know where this is
gonna go it's just gonna lead to another
big fight and i didn't wanna go through
it so tell her i'm not fighting you
and if you are physically if you
physically assault me again i'm going to
call cops
it sounds like she's trying to
manufacture emotion in that relationship
i'm not saying it's right it's wrong
but trying to just throw molotov
cocktails of passion up against the wall
to see if something sticks
does that make sense
yeah
and brother you are cashing out on a
fantasy it's not real
you know where i was cashing out was um
with with all the issues i laid out in
the beginning and then talking to this
other person it made me realize you know
what would it be like
and you said this what would it be like
if i had
dated been to someone else someone i
feel more compatible with
you're saying it's not real and i i
agree with you and i believe you but
how how do i know about without the
proof in the pudding you know what i
mean
how do you know
have you ever taken gasoline and
fertilizer
and blown up a bomb in your living room
just to see what would happen
no no have you gone to see pictures of
the federal building in oklahoma
no
google it
and you'll see one of the most
incredible acts of domestic terrorism
ever
when timothy mcveigh blew up the federal
building and killed a bunch of children
and workers
go visit that monument
you can know something isn't right
without experiencing it firsthand in
fact it would be stupid to experience
that firsthand
so if you want to detonate a bomb in
your living room go right ahead i'm
telling you what the end result is going
to be
so how do i know
you're asking the wrong question
the question is not how do i know if i'm
not missing out on something of course
you're missing out on something here's
the thing you would go out with this
woman and you'd have some great laughs
and y'all would hold hands and you'd get
all
and you'd feel all
your heart would beat and flutter and it
would be all new and blah blah blah and
it'd be
all that stuff it would be awesome
it would
and then it would be the same stuff
because you're not dealing with you
and you're not dealing this is how you
deal with friendships that start to get
messy you run
and so
what
the worst part about this new
relationship is that
bill would go with bill
and bill's the guy that just cashes out
ten-year relationships
yeah we just grew apart meh
and racism
how do i know i understand i don't know
you're asking the wrong question the
wrong question is
how do i save
my best friend
how do i save my relationship with my
best friend
how do i stop avoiding hard
conversations
how do i have hard conversations that
don't end in physical violence
you look her in the eye and say i'm not
giving up on this and this is not okay
and so i booked us an appointment a half
day with a marriage therapist here in
atlanta
and
i'm all in on this
because this is half of our life
that's how you know
if you go chasing good feelings brother
you're gonna end up miserable and alone
because there's always hard stuff to
work through in a marriage always always
always always
and what i'm going to tell you dude
is
you are worth not cashing this
relationship out
and she's not i'm not telling you that
the marriage is gonna be saved i'm not
what i'm telling you is you're looking
for the coward's way out you're looking
for a soft place to land because it's
getting uncomfortable
and you're you know what you're more
than uncomfortable you're an abusive
relationship you are okay
you're an abusive relationship and to
everyone that i am if the if the tables
were reversed
i'd be telling her to run okay so i'm
telling you you gotta flip the lights on
she can't be hitting you when you all
get in fights it's not cool no violence
in the house
but running into the arms of somebody
else as though that's gonna solve this
deal is not
accurate it's not true it's not right
so get a marriage therapist
get somebody you trust whether it's her
friend her sister
your friend your sister somebody that
both of you all trust
and you go and say i'm losing this
marriage and now all of a sudden i'm
starting thinking about plans with
somebody else and i'm not going but i'm
not losing you either
all the lights come on
you can tell her if you hit me again i'm
calling the police
you're not going to be violent in this
house
[Music]
and if you're yelling and screaming
bill stop it
be a grown-up
be mature
but don't give up this relationship this
friendship this marriage is love without
a fight
don't
don't
especially for someone who's more my
personalities fit a little bit better
don't
don't
you're worth more than this and so is
she
call somebody to date you
we'll be right back on the dr john along
show
one of the most common questions folks
ask me is what they should do in anxiety
or panic strikes like a lightning bolt
i've been helping folks 101 for years
but i wanted to create something that
everyone could use anywhere at any time
so i created a free guided meditation
it's not really a meditation but really
me just walking with you through your
anxiety alarms from start to finish i'll
guide you through a breathing exercise
and show you how to lean in listen and
head towards healing it is free and it's
for everyone you can download this
guided meditation today for free at
johndaloni.com
all right let's take one more call let's
go to aaron in
wolves kentucky what's up aaron
hey how are you good i'm still trying to
not say louisville because that's how
it's written it's louisville kentucky
louisville
louisville i love how you said that like
ah you're an idiot so i i will accept
that aaron hey so what's up how can i
help
i am calling because i have a
three-year-old and 11 month old and i
love them more than anything
but i feel like between being a mom and
work and everything that needs to be
done at home that i'm losing myself and
my joy
just in in motherhood and i don't want
to feel that way
and then in return it makes me feel like
i'm a bad mom and i know i'm not a bad
mom but
i've just
the good moms don't feel like this right
yeah
oh
i'd hug you if you were here
you have been a mom
of two little ones in the middle of a
pandemic what do you do for a living
what's your job
i'm a nurse oh geez
please i kind of i feel like um oh gosh
are you married
yeah yeah what's that
what's your partner do for a living
he does um maintenance at a local
factory so um he works a lot yeah
so he works a lot of weekends and i
think that's kind of part of my feelings
is he's a great dad and a great husband
and he always tries to help me out as
much as he can
but you know a lot of weekends he's
working and so
i told him recently that i kind of feel
like a single mom on the weekend and
by the time the weekend comes
he'll get home and ask if i'm okay and
then i'm just breaking down and i
can't really say why but i think it's
just because i'm overwhelmed yeah
and i feel bad for being overwhelmed
because
[Music]
if you really love your babies you would
just love every little second with them
and you'd never get tired or overwhelmed
and you would realize what a joy and a
privilege it is to change
crappy diapers what you're up to
probably 20 a day between the two of
them
oh and what a joy right all that stuff
right
yeah
between work and
family i
kind of take care of people all day but
at the end of the day i don't really
take care of myself there you go
lately lately it has been getting to me
where by the end of the week i'll just
be
crying i don't want to say for no reason
because obviously there's a reason but
and that's not me that's that's not um
i'm not normally like that and it's
i can really tell that it's been getting
to me over the last month or so
well i wanna
number one just honor you and say
you have been in it and i know you know
this
but i wanna validate that externally for
you
i can't think of a more
challenging scenario other than being
deployed in a combat zone i'm being
serious
potentially firefighters who are on the
on the coast right now
then a mom of two new young ones who's
also been a nurse navigating all of this
in the middle of a pandemic
on top of having a husband who's a good
guy and a hard worker but who's gone
every weekend trying to make ends
meet your body is telling you dude we've
had it we've we're at the breaking point
right
yeah and
you're a sweet little southern thing and
this is how you're supposed to keep your
house and your kids and this is how
you're supposed to smile and your hair
needs to be right
yes and and you know when i was a
teenager and in college uh you couldn't
even see like my bedroom floor i could
live in my mess and it didn't bother me
and i have become my husband was like
why are you so obsessive over our house
now he was like you used to not be like
this and and i'm i'm not obsessive like
i couldn't tell you the last time i
dusted because i don't have time to do
that
[Applause]
listen listen basic you have walked into
you've walked into
a blender
of chaos
designed to keep
professional mothers
from putting both feet on the ground
there is an ecosystem that exists
specifically designed
to tell mothers this is the way you
should be doing this this is the way you
should feel this is the way this should
look this is the way your kids should be
acting and looking this is the size of
their hair bows depending on what region
you're in this is what a wife is
supposed to be doing and looking like
and this is what a nurse is supposed to
be doing and looking like
and the whole system is designed to keep
you never feeling like you're enough
like you always are in need of one more
thing of one more minute of one more
ounce of energy of one more glass of
wine one more cup of coffee one more if
i could just get the perfect this or the
perfect that this whole machine is
designed to keep you buying crap and to
keep you off of being able to sit down
and go
right
on top of you got two humans who can't
feed themselves or bathe themselves or
use the bathroom
right yeah on top of your day job
is poking and prodding and dealing with
crazy egos above you and unrealistic
unrealistic expectations beneath you
right
and you can't
win and your body's starting to say
hey aaron
we're out
we're out
and lucky for you there's a group of
people
i mean the ecosystem here is going to
blame you for that right
so can i tell you a couple of things
that i have no business telling you
because i've never been in your sits in
your seat
okay i always feel weird answering these
kind of questions because
the last thing you need is some guy
telling you how you should be feeling
right that's the most that's the worst
thing like well actually but i will tell
you i've sat with a number of women in
the same situation right and i do get
wisdom from women who have been in the
seat okay so you ready
yes
you have lost yourself
and the old you
is not coming back
you're different now
and one of the great challenges is not
trying to quote unquote reclaim who you
used to be
the new challenge is building somebody
incredible
and what that looks like can be anything
so what's happening now is you're
comparing yourself to how much energy
you used to have
and how sexy your marriage used to be
and what a great nurse you used to be i
never used to get frustrated at having
to do this or
and now you're a new you because you
added another human and then you added
another human on top of that
right
and so things are different
and so instead of trying to drag the
past back and get the that the
quote-unquote old new back
you got to let her go
let her go she was awesome and she was
doing her thing in that time and that
time is over
now i'm a nurse in the middle of a
worldwide pandemic
i am the mother of two kids in the
middle of a pandemic
i got a husband who's trying to do
whatever and he's working like crazy in
the middle of a pandemic right so now
the the excitement and the charge is not
to reclaim what you used to be
but to build something new who you were
is gone
and
you know what kind of sucks you liked
your old self didn't you
that was fun i just say you were fun
weren't you you were fun
yes and you know my husband and i we had
it we actually did have a date night on
friday
we went to us we went to a ccr tribute
band yeah and i i really did have fun
and my husband's a music guy so he had a
blast
but if you were to look at me i didn't
look like i was having fun okay and i'm
just
here here's here's where you're at
here's here's the beauty of your moment
okay
fun is gonna look different now it might
be hey we're gonna go out and listen to
the band but i'm not gonna be dancing on
the tables anymore because i'm tired
right
what i don't want you to do is judge
take up snapshot of yourself
and impose somebody else's judgment that
somebody else wasn't even making about
you and what you should look like fun
because i don't look like i used to
now i look like this when i have fun
and it's awesome
right
yeah
and so it's not creating this this
judgment zone like here's what fun's
gonna look like we're gonna go out and
rock it on and we're gonna be in bed by
nine o'clock
all right
and we used to have
crazy middle of the afternoon rock and
roll he got home from work early and we
tore the curtains off and you know what
now once a week for this season it's
gonna be great and it's gonna be quiet
because i'm not waking the baby right
and yeah it's just gonna look different
and so the challenge now is to put a
period at the end of old sentence you
will still be fun that's who you are
you're still going to be exciting and
silly and cute and all the things the
words use
those words are still going to apply
it's just going to look different
and the way you used to judge that lady
at the show she looks like she ain't
having any fun well that's you now
right that's you now
and you get to decide whether you're
having fun
not somebody else
okay
and here's something i want you to keep
in your heart you can't control your
husband but i do think it's worth
getting out
and going to have a half day um
you've heard me say this a million times
on the show go have a half day retreat
you all got to build something new
what used to work where he was going all
day on the weekend is not going to work
in this season or
i can't keep working full-time nursing
hours right now i can't yeah
what used to be
it is got to be different and you all
got to co-create that together
yeah
yeah you just got to make space for it i
think that would be good for us too
because
i mean of course we still love each
other but it's kind of like just passing
through you're doing your thing when you
get home from work i'm doing my thing
just trying to take care of everybody
you go there
at the end of the night
then we fall asleep within five minutes
because we're so tired that's right
that's right and hey some of that is
seasonal some of that it's not it's not
just married life it's people who quit
okay it's people who quit
don't quit
there's too much fun to be had in that
marriage
you like that guy really trying to make
an effort lately because we've realized
that hey this is
not good we need to i love it i love it
i love it a few dates and
and stuff and i think one big reason for
my kind of my breaking points on the
weekend is
i'm so tired by the end of the week and
i have so much that i'm trying to do
that i feel like i don't spend enough
time with my kids during the day that
i'm like
here you go do this while i get this
done
um
and then i feel bad because i feel like
i haven't i guess been in the moment and
you you listen listen spend enough time
with my kids that's right
only you can decide quote unquote how
much time is enough time
and
you're trapped in i don't feel like i'm
doing enough you've got this imaginary
comparative standard okay and you're
going to keep chasing it and chasing it
and chasing it until you define what
that is
until you sit down and whether you get a
counselor whether you get a couple of
girlfriends whether you and your husband
go out and create this together here's
what quote-unquote enough is you're
trying to solve that burnout that's
happening in your soul by doing things
by spending time by making sure this by
cleaning that and that's not how you
heal burnout you heal burn out from rest
your heel burn out from exercise you
heal burn out from eating right you heal
burn out from having a half hour a day
to yourself
and that may mean that you're gonna have
to call somebody on saturdays a young
kid to come over and play with your
little ones while you
exhale it may mean your husband's gonna
start dropping a shift off so he can be
home with a kid so that you can go
exercise you can go for walks you can go
get your hair done whatever the thing is
right you can go join a book club
whatever it is
but where you're at now is your body's
giving you signals i want you to listen
to your body
also want you to plan and get out and
have a half day with your husband and
say all right we're a family of four now
it happened to us overnight we're
excited it's been in a pandemic
what is the next phase going to look
like let's plan it
and that keeps these fights from
happening the i'm a single mom you say
stuff that comes out of
right
and i want you to let old aaron go
and create new aaron
it's gonna be the most exciting
adventure until you have kid number
three and you can do it again or until
you have a middle schooler and you gotta
do it again and then you go to high
school but you can do it again right
you're gonna keep doing it keep doing it
keep doing it
you got this
it's exhausting
i recommend that you go talk to a
counselor too by the way you can go to
betterhelp.com if you want to do it um
from your house right
um
helps get somebody to help you build a
framework for what building the next
things are gonna look like
right and you're right to feel exhausted
i want to honor you as a hero in our
communities in our neighborhoods thank
you so so much for the nurse you are for
the mom you are for the wife you are for
the community member you are
what a gift what a gift
all right as we wrap up today's show
it's off the 2019 dragon's album he's a
neighbor out here drew holcomb and the
neighbors that was cute awesome awesome
awesome what a songwriter drew holcomb
in the neighbors the song it's called
the end of the world and it goes like
this
hey it's the end of the world now
haven't you heard so smoke them if you
got them boys and girls say goodbye to
the past now raise up your glass and
revel while it lasts it's the end of the
world sometimes i'm afraid to die my
flesh and bones won't testify my enemies
and friends share the same residence but
don't eulogize on my behalf i'm a long
way from my epitaph i'm only getting
started on this lost highway i am brave
and i'm not afraid
right here on the dr john dalone's show
you